first day so the next talk is going to
be by your time diction is going to talk
about reverse hyperconductivity and
sampling in high dimensional expanders
so take it away with them
thank you thank you for coming so yeah
first of all all I'm going to say in the
stock is joint work with Max Hopkins
from UCSD so hi Max
um yeah so as though said I'm going to
tell you about reverse hyper
constructivity and sampling in high
dimensional expanders so this is sort of
the Boolean function analysis part and
this is like the beyond the hypercube
part uh before I start though I like
prepared this like cheat sheet on high
dimensional expanders do everybody see
this part of the word
yeah so just so that we'll like converge
to the right definitions and establish
some notation so maybe I'll go through
this for a minute uh yeah so we're going
to talk about simplication complexes
basically these are just
um hyper graphs with the downward
containment property namely if you have
uh set inside the hypergraph and a
subset of it then the subset is also
part of the hypergraph
um one non-standard notation that I'm
going to use
um
uh x k like this will be all the sex x
inside X of size exactly K so I know
that the convention is to put here A K
plus one but it will be somehow more
convenient to use this uh convention
um two other uh notations one is quite
standard uh the link of a face s inside
X will just be taking all the T minus s
for T that contains s and X so probably
at least some of you have seen these
things already and I also think that you
maybe have gone over this in the boot
camp
but still it will be nice to give an
example
um so if this is sort of our simplicial
complex like these three triangles and
all edges and vertices and we look at
this like s here in the middle its link
will actually be a graph right it will
have like these two edges
A and B and
CNB
because like uh the vertex a here
corresponds to the edge sa and so on and
so on
um another thing that I want to rotate
here is the star of s or the K star of s
which will be all K faces that contain s
so for example here if we look at like
the one star
of F this will be like all these four
edges and you can see maybe why I like
the color the start
um so one last thing
um I should Define now like high
dimensional expanders basically High
dimensional expanders are these
simplicial complexes where uh the
underlying graph in every link should be
an expanded graph so this is like a
non-example because this is not even
connected
um however
um I'm only writing this down here so
that those of you who like know that
this definition already will know what
I'm talking about essentially uh for the
pack today I won't actually need this
link definition all we really need to
remember is that high dimensional
expanders sort of approximate behaviors
in the complete complex in the complex
that has like all possible sets Okay so
this is like really the the essence of
high dimensional expanders and we'll be
more precise
so
yeah so I want to tell you about reverse
hyper constructivity and essentially
this is a property of graphs that talk
about a sort of small set mixing inside
graphs so first let's define the graphs
that we will be looking at so
X will be some simplicial complex and
for the first graph that we talk about
we need two integers k and l
and this first graph is sort of the
what's called down up walk graph but let
me Define this this is a graph whose
vertices are
spaces of sides K inside X and whose
edges are just pairs that intersect with
at least L elements okay so these are
all the t1s and t2s
intersection size at least L I like to
think of this as some like specified
version of the Johnson graph because
when X is the complete complex this is
roughly the Johnson graph maybe with
equality here
um and this graph also comes with a
natural distribution that one can think
of as like generalizing the noise
distribution in the Boolean hypercube so
this distribution of choosing a pair T1
and T2
goes as follows well first we sample one
endpoint in XK and I should say this
right away
um think of X as being like very very
regular so when I say we're sampling
something out of X carry think of the
uniform distribution it doesn't have to
be like this but it will make things
simpler
um so first we sample one endpoint then
we sample a
intersection inside it so this will be
an L subset of a t that's uniformly
sampled and finally we sample T2
also in XK but conditioned on containing
this intersection s
so why do I think of this as like a
noise on T1 because again this is T1 and
you know when we choose T2 we're saying
you know we're keeping some of the
vertices so there is some correlation
however for the rest of the vertices
which will give us back T2 we're sort of
like re-randomizing uh over the
remainder of the set
um so this is like the first graph that
I want to talk about and the second
graph is even more resembling the noise
distribution because in the second graph
we won't just choose a simple fix size
XL we will actually like flip coins for
every vertex to decide whether or not we
are re-randomizing it so for the second
graph we have some parameter row between
zero and one and that's denote by J
okay row and don't worry we will always
be able to make the distinction to be a
the graph whose vertices are also x k
but this time technically the edge set
will be like all possible pairs however
the distribution will be very
non-uniform
in the way that I just described so
what we do we sampled one endpoint out
of x k next we will flip coins for like
robust coins for every vertex such that
with probability row we keep the vertex
inside the intersection and with
probability one minus rho we remove it
and then we randomize on T2 so one way
to formalize this is to say that we are
sampling L from some binomial
distribution with success probability
row and then we sample s inside T
uniformly at random
let's have this size L
um
finally we output T2 the same way we've
done for the previous graphs
okay so these are both graphs I think
that maybe Maxwell also covered this in
the boot camp that this is really sort
of a generalization of the noisy graph
and before I State formally what I want
to tell you today I want to maybe just
do this in a picture so these are you
know one of these graphs and essentially
today I want to tell you about a mixing
theorem that says that if you have here
two small sets A and B
still edges in this graph will be quite
well distributed namely we will always
find like a noticeable fraction of edges
uh going from A to B so this is quite a
nice property especially because these
graphs are not very good say expanded
graphs they're not very good spectral
expanders so like the right regime of
parameters to think about uh is maybe
like rho equals 0.9 so in this case you
can find like very small sets here where
like 90 of the addresses actually stay
inside the set so like very bad
expanders and yet you still have this
like small set mixing Lemma that says
that even if this is true the remainder
of the edges are quite well spread among
the graphs you can't like achieve like
non-trivial Independence that say due to
this like correlation between uh
substance so let me write the theorem
down formally or at least somewhat
formally
uh
the theorem
in as follows
um
let's take row to be some parameter and
let's take L to be rho K whenever I
multiply an integer with a fraction it
will always be an integer okay so I'm
not going to do integral value but let's
just assume it
um and let X be
a sufficiently good high dimensional
expander where like the Lambda parameter
goes like exponentially down with k
um so we have two parts one for each
graph for the first graph we have that
for every two subsets of the vertices
A and B
um if the relative size which I'll
denote just the probabilities of A and B
are
at least this like exponentially small
sets then
the probability of sampling an edge
in this jkl graph
such that one endpoint is an A and the
other endpoint is in b
will be at least some small polynomial
in the probabilities of A and B so of
course if this was just a complete graph
or something I could just maybe written
this here I need to put some o of one
um this like Omega constant and this o
constant both depend on row but for a
fixed row I can just write this down uh
yeah for the second graph like this is
sort of a smoothed version
uh of of this graph we get even
something smaller we actually get the
same theorem
without uh or for any
in b
even without this requirement and sizes
so sort of in in this graph you have
like some small probability of just
sampling T1 and T2 independently like if
you fail to keep any of the
intersections so somehow this takes care
of like sets that are smaller than this
and really
um even though I'm stating this for
these two graphs this is really the
graph that we're going to focus on and
this is like where the heart of the
proof is
um yeah so this is called small foot
mixing and before I tell you about sort
of how this goes and why this is
connected to sampling I would like to
maybe uh mention a couple of words on
the history of such inequalities and why
I I like to call it a reverse
hypercontractive inequality so let's uh
think back on the Boolean hypercube uh I
want to maybe keep this
uh what should I erase
I'm going to erase this cheat sheet
okay so back maybe to the Boolean
hypercube
um so let's denote by
0 the row correlated
noise operator namely tiro
Opera operates on a function X
gives us another function that's an
input X where X is In N bit string it
outputs the average of f
overwise that our row correlated with x
and when I say row correlated again like
we uh um the randomness here is by
taking a x for every coordinate flipping
a coin with probability row we keep the
value of x with probability one minus
rho we randomize so this is the
expectation here
um the
well-known hyper-contractive theorem by
I think bonami and also Beckner and goth
and Nelson
um it is the following so suppose we
have
p and Q where Q is greater than p and
suppose we take a correlation that is
small enough with respect to these
p's and q's then it turns out that for
every function if
the Q form of the noise operator of f is
less or equal to the peace Norm
okay and here just so we recall the
peace Norm of a function f is of course
the expectation of f in absolute value
to the p and then we take a piece root
and what's important about these Norms
is that they're monotone so that if I
take Q to be larger and larger the norm
should increase and increase or at least
it should be greater or equal to the
piece Norm but here what this ethereum
is saying is that this noise operator
shrinks F so much that even if I measure
it in the Q Norm which should make it
bigger it's still less or equal to F in
like the original Peak Norm
um so this is like the standard
hyper-contractive theorem and it also
has apparently a reverse
hypercontractive ethereum where I can
actually like reverse this inequality
this sounds like nonsense uh but let me
let me state it for you
um and this I think is due to
Morel in the 80s and now something weird
is going to happen here now we're going
to take p and Q
less than one
and we're going to say that if rho
still small enough
then it turns out that the
I'll call it Q Norm of T row f is
actually bigger than the peace Norm of f
so you know let's let's process this for
a minute first of all when P or Q is are
less than one this is not a norm anymore
okay so this is not convex you don't
have like a triangle inequality
still I mean you can Define you you can
Define this
let's for convenience ask F to be a
non-negative function uh this is of
course necessary uh here
um okay so you can still Define this and
it still makes sense to maybe compare
these things and it turns out that you
know you can you can actually get an
analogous result if you sort of reverse
the arrows here and you reverse the
arrows here uh
however I mean this seems quite abstract
and it actually has an equivalent two
function version that is like much
easier to understand and to actually
find out like how this theorem came from
so actually the two function version
here will say that for every
f and g if we look at the expectation of
f x and g y
where X is uniform
um over the Boolean hypercube and Y is
noised up
and this expectation is greater or equal
to
the pth norm of f times the Helder
conjugate a norm Q Prime of G so here Q
Prime
like formally it's Q over Q minus one
and I really encourage you to think
about this theorem in the parameter
regime where like uh p and Q Prime are
some like uh positive constant of course
less than one
Okay so
why do I like this two function version
the reason is it actually makes sense
when you put your indicators of
functions so when I will put your
indicators of functions what we actually
get is
is what
so suppose f is the indicator of some
subset A and G is the indicator of
subset B the left hand side of this
inequality well it just simplifies to
the probability of sampling X and Y as
an easy copy such that one endpoint is
an A and the other endpoint is in b
and whereas this right hand side uh this
will be well it's not too hard to follow
this expression if this is an indicator
function this P power or absolute value
doesn't matter so this really is like
the probability of a to b 1 over P the
probability of B to the
1 over Q Prime
so if you believe me that this is
equivalent if you instantiate this to
indicator functions then you you will
get that this thing is actually also
like the probability of a times the
probability of B to be all of one so I
should say that like this observation
was first done by Mossel O'Donnell is
regabs
and they actually prove this very useful
like small set mixing
inequality in the Boolean hypercube
um and and they used it for like a
application then some communication
problem with many parties uh later this
also found applications in like uh in
agreement testing and uh
um like in robust social Choice theorems
and
it's really quite a nice theorem for the
Boolean hypercube uh
from that's this version Oh that's
actually a good question uh the answer
is sort of yes for if you have this for
uh if you have this for all sets and
you're willing to satisfy to be
satisfied with slightly worse fees in Q
primes here
and maybe also maybe like a fixed
constant here you you can do it actually
um we also do it in the paper just
because we didn't find anywhere that
this was done
but uh that may be a better answer to
your question is that well yes but
really when people use this reverse
hyperconstructivity all they really care
about is this I mean like I think that
in every single application or
at least the ones that I read this is
what's interesting uh but formerly
mathematically you can get back
good uh
yeah so
I'll continue here
um okay so this is maybe the history or
why we call it reverse hyperconductivity
and now that we know this I want to tell
you something about the proof here and
the first thing I want to do is to
convince you that this question of
mixing is actually a question of
sampling okay
um and the reason is as follows
um
yeah so look at this look at this
distribution over here which is the
Distribution on edges actually it can be
equivalently viewed as a distribution
where we first sample this intersection
so we treat it like a first class
Citizen and then we will just sample T1
and T2 sort of independent from one
another so like the equivalent
distribution here is really first
sampling s
which is the intersection and then
sampling uh P1 and T2 that contain s
independency from one another so this
probability that T1 is in a
and T2 is in b
we can of course write it as
the expectation over this intersection
in the first step of the probability
given that T1 and T2 contain s
but because these things are independent
this is just really
this expectation
over s of the probability that over like
the relative size of a and the relative
sizes of B inside the star of s so like
the picture
should be or maybe I will just like
decrypt this notation
PA given s is just like a intersect the
K star of s
divided by the K star of s
and you know
notorially
one side
XL on the other side and we sort of look
at like these containment neighborhood
or the spontainment graph and you know
we have like two sets here A and B
and this like expectation is really
asking the question how many s's see in
their like containment neighborhood or
like in their star they see a and b
with at least some like noticeable or
non and negligible probability uh
because this is all that's going on here
so this sort of motivates us to ask how
well do high dimensional uh expanding
like how well do these containment
graphs in high dimensional expanders
actually uh sample small sets uh of
Dimension higher
so that with this intuition in mind uh
I'd like to uh
I'd like to define a very useful
primitive in computer science which is
called sampler graphs there are some
definitions out there not all of them
are exactly equivalent but they are very
similar essentially a sampler graph is a
graph where one side really samples sets
on the other side quite well so
maybe we'll draw another picture
suppose we have a bipartite graph with
left or left and right sides
and suppose we have some
set a on the left who has some relative
size which will denote ypa
um so we can say maybe that the vertex
samples a well on the right
if
when viewing its neighborhood on the
left the relative size of a inside this
neighborhood is roughly the relative
size of like the global a inside all uh
on the left side so we really want that
like the
inside the neighborhood
would be approximately the probability
of a so this vertex is good but I don't
know maybe like this vertex U Prime is
bad because it almost doesn't see
anything inside a or maybe the C prime
prime is also bad because I don't know
maybe it's like completely contained or
almost completely contained in a and a
sampler graph is really a graph where
like most of the vertices on the right
will be like with vertex U and not these
so
uh I think this is a nice uh this is a
nice definition it has many uses in like
uh error correcting codes and and saving
Randomness uh so the definition goes as
follows so for a fixed graph G and some
subset a in the left let's denote by T
of a to be like the bad vertices in the
right so these will be all the use on
the right side
so that inside their neighborhood either
we see a
with more than three halves its original
a relative size or we see it
less than a half
so these are like the vertices that
Temple a atypically
and for some parameters uh Alpha and
beta
we say that g is a
alphabeta
sampler
if for every set
a
of probability at least Alpha this will
be the set size bound
we have that at most beta
a better fraction of the vertices sample
a battery
okay so for every a most of the vertices
will sample a quite well
um
so I I want to give some examples for
this definition so it will maybe be less
mysterious
foreign
be the complete complex example so
uh let's take our graph to be
left side is some universe and sized
right side I'll denote it by
this notation namely all possible
subsets a random size exactly K and the
edges will be containment Edge so like V
is adjacent to us if V contains s
um so by like standard chain of bounds
one can show that for every set a the
probability of the vertices on the right
sample a badly
is at most
some exponent uh to the minus K times
the probability of a squared and why is
this true
well roughly let's think of K as some
constant and N is much larger than k
here like sampling uh a node in the
right this is roughly just like sampling
K vertices on the left
independently I mean of course there is
some probability when we sample
independently that there will be a
collision but like ignoring that we're
in K is like very small this is roughly
the same thing so this is just a churn
of bound
um and in fact one can show that for a
graph with right side degree K this is
essentially optimal this is a theorem by
I think kanathy Evan and or the Gold
Reef
um so really this is like the most that
we can expect and we indeed get it of
course uh if you like if you like to
save in Randomness and things like that
this is like very inefficient there are
a whole bunch of vertices uh here which
like people have tried to take down
[Music]
the second example that will be more
modest and parameters is just that if G
is a Lambda
spectral expander
okay so it's a bipartite graph but it
can be a one-sided Lambda expander
um you will still get for every Alpha
greater or equal to zero that g is sort
of an alpha uh
roughly Lambda squared over Alpha
just to compare because I don't think I
wrote it here on the board oh
here
G is like an alpha e to the minus Alpha
squared over three a k
example
so here you can get something that's
like polynomial in the degree whereas
here you get something exponential still
sometimes you know what you have to work
with is only a spectral expander and
this bound could still be useful and in
fact like in previous works of high
dimensional expansion like you know when
carphone's work on agreement expanders
or the neuro livni Kaufman hausa and
tashman's work on constructing locally
list decodable codes like this was
mainly what was used spectral map does
achieve like good enough sampling for
some applications
um the main technical tool that Max and
I needed to show this reverse hyper
constructivity is actually stronger
sampling than what you can get from a
spectral Bound in these containment
graphs of high dimensional expanders
yeah
here well G is a graph so it must be
along one-sided the spectral expander
because you always have like this minus
one
this is not the spectral expansion of
the complexes no this is just like for
playing graphs this is not this is just
an example one
um I'll comment on that in a minute okay
um
[Music]
so
dilemma that
the following so let X be a
297k
remember here you can either take a
two-sided High dimensional expander you
can take some multi-part type one-sided
high-directed expanders but they need to
be like a cut of like a polynomial
polynomial in the dimension this is like
a technical property but this can could
be extended slightly
then the following graph is a very good
sampler so what will be the graph so the
scrap would have a uh so let's Maybe
parameters
i j and k and that's maybe fix the
things are PSI
the left side of this graph will be the
r star okay the right side of this graph
will be the r star
of 11j engine will be of course edge of
the containment
and the sampling property that we uh
achieved
is that
if you have a set size bound which is
exponential inters
K minus I divided by J minus I
you will get a confidence
that's a small constant
this is roughly the technical tool that
I want to tell you about
um but let's talk about this a little
first of all
um like the like the first use case that
you maybe want to consider is like what
happens when I equals 0 and R is just
the empty set in this case this is just
x k this is just x j and we get this
like a containment graph
um
the rest actually follows from like the
general case that I wrote here sort of
actually follows just from the fact that
like the star is sort of isomorphic to
the link and the link is also a good
high dimensional expander so like this
is not only like the first case you
think about this is like almost a
general uh case so I like to think about
it like this but it will be useful later
to also consider like these local
components these Stars
um another couple of things I want to
say about Islam I I don't think I'll
have time to prove it uh to you
um first of all I should say that
um there is a work by impalazo cabinets
and digital Zone from 2008 that showed
roughly the same Lemma for the complete
complex
foreign
you know whenever you see such a
statement on the complete complex it
sort of challenges you to say ah you
know you don't really need a complete
complex you can do this in high
dimensional expanders so like it turns
out that you can
and uh the proof it mainly goes through
like a previous sort of pseudo-random
result in high dimensional expanders by
already know and myself which is called
like the high dimensional expander
mixing Lemma and I will just say that
sort of you can also like generalize
this and we like try to slightly
generalize this to also other uh
interesting hypergraphs so you can get
somewhat of a similar theorem also if
you look at like Works in an expander or
like other what's called like splitable
trees for those who know this for those
who don't this is not such an important
comment
um yeah finally uh the last thing I want
to say about this Lemma is that
um
in fact this maybe parameter regime is
not what people usually like to look at
usually people like that like the set
size bound is constant and the
confidence is like really really uh high
or really really low if we we look at
beta like as the bad like the
probability of the bad set and it turns
out that sort of if you flip sides here
namely you take like the small side to
be the side that sampled and the large
side to be the side that that samples
like clay sets versus gay sets you can
also like reverse the parameters here so
you can get like a small constant of
your set size bound and a large constant
sorry not a large constant and an
inverse exponent here in the confidence
and like this is this also found
applications in like in paliato cabinet
and victorians work so I don't know
maybe this generalization to like sparse
or synchristial complexes
um could also still be interesting
yeah any questions here
Michael J is that kill where two you're
not getting
yeah so for J and K to be constant this
is uh this is quite uh weak right
because this is only a constant here
um you need to think about this as when
J is like really small like I don't know
like a square root of K or even a
constant well in this parameter regime
then the what you're about faster from
the spectral Gap is something that we
have like one over Alpha to one over
Alpha k or something whereas here this
is like an exponent in an exponent in a
minus k
minus square root K so really the power
here is when J is like incomparable to K
but then you don't have a like
you don't have like a
polynomials
exponential expected to get better like
yeah you also assume that very rich
um so what do you mean by we expected
expansion right it's like inverse
exponential in UK
okay yeah okay I'll say something okay I
think of like I have zero so this is
just x k versus XJ When J is one then
this roughly achieved the parameters you
get through the complete complex so you
can't expect and I think or even J
equals two or I don't know square root k
or something like that well uh I don't
know how much better this can get I mean
we haven't tried or we haven't tried
very hard you need to try also in the
complete complex because better things
are not known even there so uh I mean it
could be true I'm not sure
definitely for that case you don't have
like some optimality uh lower bound or
something it could potentially be better
so
now that we have like all the players in
the proof I like to give you a rough
sketch
of how one showed this reverse
hyper-contractive inequality
so let me remind what the setup is to
this is theorem so recall that we have
some good enough High dimensional
expander uh
and when I say good enough I mean high
dimension or expander such at the
previous Lemma holes that's like really
all we need uh we have two sets A and B
which are vertices in this like jkl
subset of vertices in the jkm graph and
all we know about them
is that they are no smaller than some
what exponent in k
um
and for Simplicity let's fix like row to
be one over four L to be K over four uh
I should say this is like a minor
technicality when like row gets closer
to one you need to introduce some more
complexity to this proof but still most
of the ideas will suffice here and this
is like still linear in K and what we
want is to show that if I sample T1 and
T2 in this
[Music]
it's like sparsified Johnson graph j k l
k over four this would be greater or
equal to the probability of a times the
probability of B
the old one so this is what we
want to show
um
and now
I want to draw this like containment
graph and it will have soon multiple
layers so I will draw it like
horizontally
so here's XK
here we have two sets that could be like
inverse exponentially small but I'll
draw them slightly larger just because
uh just for the picture and
you know here's
x k over 4.
and a fan pointed out I mean if these
sets had like some I don't know like a
small constant size we could have just
you know said that like for at least
like maybe half the s's over here they
would sample A and B
well enough like up to like losing a
factor of half but of course this is not
true right because we don't know that
they're constant instead we know that
they uh
they have said that the most like
inverse exponential in k
however note that what we need to prove
is not that this thing this probability
is lower bounded by a constant times
these two probabilities we need to prove
something much weaker when a and b gets
smaller we need to prove that this is
only greater or equal to this product of
probabilities to I don't know to the
seventh power so like the smaller A and
B gets like the more room for error that
we have we don't need such a strong
sampling theorem so what we're going to
do is sort of try to like accumulate
more errors along the way and and and
yet still use the sampling theorem where
it will actually apply for a and b
so with this in hand the trick will
actually be that when we sample s
in
x k over 4 we won't sample it in one
shot we will sample it in batches
so okay so we think of s is like a k
over four sets but we will sample it
like J vertices at a time so R1 R2 R3
and so on up to I don't know RB which
will be the number of times we need to
do this so
Jay I think of it as the best size
and for the moment let's think of Js
just being like 100 vertices or
something later on we should optimize
this okay but let's think about it like
that and B will be the number of
veterans we need which is of course k
over 4G
and the point is
that when this J is indeed a constant
then even if a and b were actually this
small
we will still be able to use this
sampling property okay because when J is
a constant and you should think of I
also as a constant here then this will
be like e to the minus k
okay so the trick is again think of
explains like way down below here
and we will sample things in XJ and then
we will gradually go up until we get to
x k over 4.
so
so what can we say actually about uh
what can we say about XJ well for the
first R for the first r that we sample
for the first J vertices there we
actually know that our sampling is our
sampling graph will be small will be
strong enough because
these are bounded by this quantity and J
is a constant so like for the first K
vertices we can actually sample A and B
quite well so towards this maybe we
Define
like this good set G1
which will be
all the vertices such that A or B in
their star
is off by at most a half
and because we know that
this graph is the e to the
Omega K 0.25
sampler and because we know that A and B
are large enough we know that if our
is not in G1 this means that R is either
in the bad set of a or the bad set of B
which means that G1
as relative size at least to have so
like for the first R vertices half of
them are good uh
let's do one
what about the next server diffuse so
now I've sampled like one subset the
vertices I still haven't gone to uh gone
all the way but now I'm only worried
about sampling the next
our vertices so I like to think about it
like this now we're looking at
2J
we've already sampled our one hopefully
it wasn't this like good set and now
sampling another R2 is actually sampling
you know is sampling R1 Union R2 or this
joint Union from the J star of R so this
is the
uh
uh sorry the 2D star of r
okay so we have a two-day vertices J of
which are inside R and of course
provided that R landed inside this good
set we know that if we look at the star
versus star graph so if we look all the
way up
onto the
hey Star Bar
we know that over here
A and B
well if I was good they may have been
smaller but they're only smaller by a
factor of half so still a factor of half
we can still use this bound
so
again there is some deterioration in
parameters that you need to carefully
like Chase but this star graph
will also be
e to the minus Omega K 0.25 Center
and so if you define the fit
G2 which are on the things in with 2J
vertices so that in the star
we are off by a factor but most a
quarter
so it's like half squared
okay then I claim that the probability
of this G2
is itself greater or equal to a quarter
and why is this simple
we're sampling this set G2 so you know
first we sampled R1 if it's in the bad
set okay we lose but it's in the good
set with probability half so you know so
like with probability half
R1 is in G1 what about R2 well here are
you sampling given that R1 was in G1 we
know that half of the R1 r2s
inside here sample A and B really well
with respect to their size inside the R1
star which is at least half their
original probability so
probability another half
um
R1 and R2
samples
A and B
so this is roughly it so now
you know we will Define also G3 for 3j4
and so on and
up until you maybe arrive at sort of GB
where B is the batch size and these will
be all sets of size K over four
such that in their star
we are off binomial of a factor of 2 to
the minus B
foreign
this is like a very typical inductive
proof in high dimensional expanders you
sort of start with something Global and
then you like condition on a link of a
star or something and then you may be
condition on something else and you go
up up all the way until you get like
this recursive or induction uh or
inductive argument
and I claim that this suffices because
uh
because of course the probability that
a good event happens which is this
expectation
well this is just greater or equal to
the probability of GB
times the smallest value this thing can
get given that this is in GB which is
equal to the minus 2B
PA P capital B I am now noticing that I
used Little B and capital B so I'm
saying b a lot I I apologize
foreign
so of course
here the correct analog of what we are
proving here like half a quarter and so
on will also be that this GB set
will have a size that's also like
inverse exponential in b
and if you can actually prove this which
we do this is at most sorry at least
through to the sum exponential in b
e
oh you know this will maybe a bit
technical but all we really need to
understand here is that if you use if
you analyze using this technique the
error that you incur is really
exponential in the number of batches
that we take so like the name of the
game here is to like carefully balance
these parameters so on the one hand you
want to take as many vertices per batch
as you can so you will incur less error
on the other hand if you take too many
uh
too many vertices then you won't be able
to use like the sampling Lemma
um but it turns out uh that if you use a
large enough constant say 100
foreign
this argument will actually work so you
can
lower bound this bye
paapv
to some small power
yeah uh
maybe I'll just give some concluding
remarks and I'll finish here
um so this was sort of a
combinatorial proof to like a reverse
hyper hyper constructive inequality that
I felt that maybe had like a different
flavor than like the more analytic
proofs that you see for like uh you know
for the Boolean hypercube or other
places where you can sort of do
something in like a two-point space and
tensorize or maybe use like uh log
several of inequalities
um so I was wondering whether there was
like a more analytic way to also view
this proof or also view these proofs in
high dimensional expanders so this is
like one question that I maybe want to
post to the audience if somebody wants
to think about it uh
another thing that I sort of view is
like someone that caveat in this work
um which is also a caveat like in a lot
of Works in high dimension on expanders
that this is really requiring a lot I
mean you know High dimensional expanders
are very uh they're very rare objects
you can't just like sample one like from
a natural random distribution and here
not only you need a high dimensional
expander you need like an extremely good
high dimension of expander like the
expansion parameter is like uh inverse
exponential in k
and you know like in nature sometimes
you can prove High dimensional expansion
but maybe it's not like uniform in all
levels and maybe it's not exponential in
K and
I mean these like mixing inequality seem
quite useful so I mean what can we say
for other structures or even for high
dimensional expenditures that are like
weaker than this like very strong
guarantee
this is a good place to end
thank you for listening
any questions for your thumb
uh yeah that's a good question I don't
think it extends technology complexive
uh
I mean maybe you can try and tailor like
the proof details to Metroid complexes
as well but but uh no I I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if you could
extend this this like they're very
structured right they're like almost
apartheid
knows
the complete complexity
[Music]
so if you want yeah
foreign
[Music]
I admit I'm not sure what what's known
in the like prior dance case I imagine
that these techniques will be weaker in
wherever like uh
I mean this is not this is also probably
not Optimum in the parameters and like
really
the advantage here is only that you can
work over like sparser sets I don't know
if well I think I'm very interesting to
me because
your set is loud because in many
external problems it looks like
diversity is no a way of walking because
it somehow holds for all sets
to understand yeah and somehow the fact
that you manage to put some photos
thank you
yeah maybe I'll just mentioned just for
the last minute that this this
requirement is actually also necessary
so you can like so not a very
complicated example where this like and
we have times 2 to the minus K and and
they have no uh
okay we'll respect to that is the
inspector expansion parameter and then
get something for
[Music]
in this context
yeah uh I guess that for uh nice
gamma is due to the mind of something
and make the noise
okay
like what is hiding here like the
theorem that I stated in a simplified
way sort of tells you that you are a
you're a sampler with like uh with error
probability that's like e to the I don't
know okay something plus an error which
is of the form like two to the K or
three to the care something times Lambda
and sort of there so like if you are a
small exponential then this is roughly
like this then once you're a large
exponential you get something that could
be much larger than I mean even for
exponentially small number this could be
much harder than one so you did nothing
um
um so so again this really only comes up
like in the proof of development
you know it's from some other source you
can you can do this
any other questions
you can't push the confidence level
yeah
one two five
oh uh you I just simplified you there's
a parameterized version where this is
that fine this is maybe like e to the
minus Alpha squared times what I wrote
and I just didn't want to
[Music]
okay so let's thank you again
[Applause]
will return after lunch at 2PM
foreign